foreign
[Music]
I am the senior director of biopharmor
product strategy at twist bioscience and
I've LED teams across the whole
organization in the development of DNA
tools and today we'll be talking about
the importance of hybrid capture
technology to recognize and characterize
viral threats
so in this talk it will cover the
following topics there will be
differences in diagnostic assays for
detecting viruses we'll go into an
overview of what next Generation
sequencing hybrid capture is and then
we'll go into some case studies and how
hybrid capture can be used for detector
and detect detecting excuse me and
characterizing viral threats
so broadly speaking there are different
types of FDA approved and feature
Diagnostics there are diagnostic tests
there are serology and antibody tests or
other adaptive immune response tests and
then there are tests for the management
of patient care in this talk we'll
highlight diagnostic assays for the
detection of viral diseases
so when determining the right type of
test it's important to understand the
course of infection and how viral loads
can change during that infection so here
on the right excuse me on the left we're
highlighting the Infectious Disease for
uh profile of 19. specifically the viral
load of styrofo V2 you can see that in
the pre-infectious phase the viral load
is quite low and then during that
infectious period the virus loads goes
very high and then over the course of
the of the illness the viral lobe
decreases and so there are two lines on
this chart one a low analytical
sensitivity neither is a high analytic
substitute and that's because different
types of tests have different
throughputs and different uh thresholds
and what the virus load that they can
create and and actually they're capable
of detecting
so the type of in vitro diagnostic can
really impact test results because if
you're using a low analytic sensitivity
test in the beginning of the infection
you may miss the presence of the virus
whereas it would be picked up by a high
analytically sensitive test like PCR
some assays and tests can determine the
presence of multiple pathogens in one
assay so sorry II for example has very
similar symptoms to influenza or
rhinoviruses and so some tests are able
to differentiate between the types of
pathogens that may exist or the type of
viruses that are present and then
mutating viruses can evade certain
assays so if you're working with immune
a virus that mutates very rapidly it's
important to understand that and then
take the test that best suits that
particular virus so there are different
methods for detecting viral infections
and again if you use Sarasota V2 as an
example on the schematic to the right
you can see different options and so
those are also highlighted in the text
to the left
there are molecular assays which uses
molecular biology and typically PCR
amplification to detect for the presence
of small amounts of nucleic acids there
are antigen tests which uses antibodies
to capture specific antigens proteins in
this case and then there are serology
tests
so it's important to distinguish the
antigen tests and molecular assays can
detect for the presence of an infection
that's currently happening so the
presence of the virus in the body or
because molecular assays are so
sensitive presence of viruses that error
infections that you may have just
cleared where serology tests indicate
that you may have been infected
and all the assays have different pros
and cons molecular assays are capable of
detecting very small amounts of nucleic
acids they're incredibly sensitive
whereas the benefits of antigen tests
they're portable and they have results
within 5 to 15 minutes an antigen test
that's very familiar to most consumers
would be something like a pregnancy test
and while pregnancy is not analysis or a
virus it's the same principle it detects
for a specific proteins and then and on
that test you get a line or two lines
you can apply that same technology for
viral detection
now I've highlighted and twist teal the
molecular assays and that's because in
this talk we'll be focusing on different
types of molecular assays that you can
use for detecting viral infections
and so again if we use starts with V2 as
an example we've just highlighted the
genome and the different components of
that genome across the schematic at the
top and so it's composed of multiple
open reading frames the orf1a the orf1ab
and then different proteins like Spike
protein the envelope protein the nuclear
capsid and what you see here in the
arrows are basically locations for where
certain molecular tests bind in for the
section of that genome and so if I break
up molecular assays in very broad terms
they could be simply characterized as
PCR based or sequencing based and so PCR
based assays include rtpcr real-time PCR
or quantitative PCR to PCR in digital
droplet PCR
and those methods use probes or specific
primers to bind to specific regions of
the genome and it's used to detect and
to measure the metavirus present and so
on the far right you'll see a tiny
little chart with an example of rtpcr
amplification cycles and what you should
see in that chart is that the signal the
Baseline is very very low until a
specific cycle number and then there's
exponential amplification of that signal
now at that point we're exponential
amplification happens is the cycle
threshold the CT value and oftentimes
you'll hear viral loads represented in
terms of their CT value like a patient
is positive for specific disease if the
CT value is higher than X or lower than
y
um there are also sequencing based
assays like amplicons frequencing and
Next Generation sequencing hybrid
capture or Target enrichment which we
call I will be using the terminology
ngste
now those two methods um can amplify the
whole genome amplicon sequencing uses a
series of PCR primers that overlap and
they use those parameters to amplify
regions of the viral genome typically
followed by some type of Next Generation
sequencing where hybrid capture or MGS
Target enrichment and gste will use
nucleic acid probes to enrich for the
viral genome from complex sample input
and so when I see things like this my
first question is what do I use like
what's the best assay uh how do these
methods compare and so if I look at
viral identification in applications
there are certain differences between a
sequencing approach like Target
enrichment and a two-pcr approach and
we've just highlighted some of them here
so both qpcr or real-time PCR are highly
sensitive and they're capable of
detection so can they present they can
they detect the presence of the virus
Check Yes
the sensitivity depends on the type of
test but it can be very highly sensitive
the Hands-On time is a significant
difference so qpcr is fast and rapid and
oftentimes you can get results within 15
minutes to 30 minutes to an hour whereas
Target enrichment that workflow is
significantly longer
can you do multiple diagnosis in one
reaction sometimes yes for both Target
enrichment and qpcr it depends on the
kit and then both will be able to give
you an estimated jar of tagger now where
they differ is that Target enrichment or
hybrid capture sequences for the entire
genome it's capable of
using this method for surveillance and
tracking the way that the virus has been
transmitted and moved across the
population over time
and it's also capable of looking at
geomutations and viral evolution so
let's go into whole genome or whole
viral whole viral virus sequencing in a
little bit more detail
so the advantages of whole virus
sequencing is with mutated viruses
sequence monitoring and surveillance are
really important and again to use a very
relevant example here what you see on
the left is a is a heat map excuse me is
an alignment of the cyroscope E2 virus
the original strain or the wild type
strain compared to the uh the virus as
it evolves over over time
and so all the bands that you see in
those different colors indicate the
presence of a mutation or snip or
deletion and so viral sequencing will
give important information on the
evolution of this virus and how it's
been transmitted across
cross populations
and like I said earlier amplicon and
Target enrichment are two high uh two
whole virus sequencing approaches so how
do amplicon sequencing and Target
enrichment compare
um
so how does ngsp compare to amplicon
sequencing and in this experiment what
we've done is we've used Next Generation
sequencing Target enrichment and we've
compared that to a specific kit that is
used for Amplified sequencing called
Arctic for Sarco V2 him it's been used
Arctic has been used to amplify a Prost
genome and then was sequenced on two
Next Generation frequency platforms are
there alumina platforms or Oxford
nanopore and what you're seeing here is
the distribution across the sequences on
the on the y-axis is the intensity of
the signal and on the x-axis is the map
of the sr-52 genome and you can see that
the Arctic primers in top on with the
blue headers they're spiky they go up
and down and the coverage isn't very
eaten whereas when you use Next
Generation sequencing it leads to even
coverage across the whole genome and
that's really important
because if you're a researcher and
you're looking for a certain snip or a
certain region of interest that may be
mutated you want to make sure that you
have enough coverage at that area if
you're an epidemiologist and you want to
see how to mutate the population uh in
uh can be mutated and how the you know
the mutation moves through populations
it's also really important to get even
coverage
so before we dive into specifically
ngspe for viral detection let's give a
little bit of background on how Next
Generation Target number sequencing
Target enrichment works in the general
workflow hmm
so next Generation Target enrichment I
like to think of it as pulling a needle
out of the haystack so if I think about
if I am a patient and I'm infected with
a specific virus if I gener if I extract
all of the nucleic acids that are
present within a population within a
sample whether that sample input the
saliva nasal swab you know blood there
will be a lot of my DNA a lot of my
human DNA and just a small fraction of
the viral DNA and so what Target
enrichment does is it takes DNA probes
for the twist of thumb and it binds to
specific populations so if you look at
the schematic on the slide for whole
genome sequencing you may only be
interested in one sequence of interest
but when you do that sequencing
that sequence of interest will be uh in
a very small fraction of your population
but using Next Generation Target Next
Generation sequencing Target enrichment
or ntspe you can pull out the sequence
of Interest
and so with the same sequencing coverage
you have many many more representations
of the sequence of interest and so when
looking at ngste you look for is
uniformity of those sequences you look
at High coverage and you want to
basically use this to maximize your
sequence efficiency
excuse me so the basic ngste workflow is
such you start with your sample and you
prepare it for the downstream steps you
go and you create a library of it so you
take your components
you create it so it's adaptable to your
sequencing platform you then go into
Target enrichment so you take that
population your whole input and then you
put it through your pro uh you put it
through your hybridization with Pros and
you pull down only the sequence of
Interest
then you go into sequencing and into
analysis
there are many different types of
chemistries when doing ngste
such as fast time and standard Hive and
south side is capable of going from
sample to a sequencer in a single day
and so what I've highlighted here are
the different reaction steps from your
library prep as a precursor
and then going into pulling your samples
hybridizing binding and washing how long
it takes to go to the to be available to
go into sequencing and like I said ntste
is very flexible so you can do a fast
side to get to a sequencer in one day or
if you have certain workflows you can
let it go overnight and so it's ready
for the sequencer when you come in the
next morning
now when evaluating Target enrichment
uniform capture oftentimes starts with
uniform DNA synthesis
so if you're using a DNA probe to pull
down sequences you want to make sure
that all of your probes are basically
uniformly covered before you put it into
your population
and so if you have something that's
highly uniform and you have a method for
detection for pulling those sequences
down you'll end up with a highly uniform
pool at the end and that's demonstrated
with the twist amplification method on
the right
where all of those humps indicate where
a prophet bind and then you get the same
representation of each basic hump each
probe region with the uniform synthesis
and uniform capture now if you have
methods where you take something that
may be synthesized uh but then you
amplify or create those probes in a way
that causes bias then you're going to
cause bias pull down
the samples that you get out will have
different representations that may not
exist within nature because what you use
to pull down or capture your sequence of
interest is by in that scene on the
plots to the left where all of those
humps which indicates where probes are
have either under sequenced or
oversequenced
so you know coverage distribution
if you want to make sure that when you
have a probe design and again those
different humps indicates regions that
are being pulled down by specific probes
you want all of those probes to come
down it's a bind to your target that's
relative efficiency
and that will increase and improve how
you do coverage moving forward and so
the plot to your right looks at the
number of faces that are covered using
Next Generation sequencing
if you have improved coverage
then you can use less sequencing to get
the same information and that's
incredibly valuable because sequencing
is often the most expensive part of the
process
now measuring the quality of Target
enrichment there are a few key metrics
including uniformity
which is also
represented as a fold 80 based base
penalty
and so basically to the plot on the
right you have again that schematic but
the different humps that recognize that
represent different probe regions since
DNA was pulled down at that probe region
if you have under sequenced or over
sequenced region the full of 80s how
much more sequencing is needed to bring
every everything up to 80 of the basis
to The observed mean value
there's specificity so if you're
designing probes to pull down specific
sequences of DNA you want to make sure
that those probes bind what you think
they'll be and so if your probe designed
is poor or if something happens you'll
get off Target where your post will pull
down sequences
that aren't of Interest and then you
also want to look at the library
complexity so the the environment that
you're pulling sequences down are very
complex you want to make sure that you
maintain that complexity through hybrid
capture and that they're sequencing and
that's seen as HS Library size and the
duplication rate for viral capture other
key metrics are depth of coverage and
the percent of the virus that is covered
so we'll go into three different panels
and some positive controls for viral
detection and characterization so the
three ngste panels that I'll be
discussing have different yeast domains
first off there's a SARS cov2 research
panel and that can be used for the high
sensitivity enrichment for Star sub E2
there's a respiratory research panel
which is used for high sensitivity
detection of a variety of human
respiratory pathogens would like
diseases like influence sorry with like
symptoms like influenza rhinoviruses and
sarcopy too and then there's
comprehensive research panel will go
into which can detect novel viruses or
highly Divergent viral streams
while also talking about we'll also talk
about the importance of viral controls
and so I've highlighted some viral
controls either through viral variance
of cyresco V2 or other respiratory viral
controls and so what I have here on the
right is just an example again another
schematic of uh pulling specific viral
strains down that are synthetic viral
controls that have set point mutations
compared to the wild type sequence and
you can see again either with this Gap
that indicates that deletion in the
bottom panel or those highlighted Snips
of different colors the Next Generation
sequencing was able to characterize the
full virus
and then also correctly identify where
those point mutations were
excuse me so so I mentioned synthetic
viral controls and synthetic controls
are an important tool for asset
Developers
what I've highlighted here are some
sarasco V2 controls and then some
respiratory virus controls and so what
we've done a Twist is we've created
synthetic viral controls
that are synthesized through Genesis
through DNA synthesis and they have the
final format of their virus either RNA
single stranded double stranded or
double stranded or single stranded DNA
and the beauty of these synthetic
controls
is that since they rely on Gene
synthesis they can be rapidly generated
so instead of waiting for a patient to
be unfortunately infected and then
extracting that sequence once it's been
puts out sequences they've been
identified through any means Genesis or
Gene synthesis can be used to rapidly
synthesize that sequence also another
benefit is that they're available to
using bsl1 labs and so no specialized
permits are required
uh it's easy to transmit they won't
cause infectivities so it gives broader
access to more developed Labs that may
not have specialized DSL two or three
level labs
I love synthetic controls because as an
acid developer myself sometimes it's
hard to find the proper control
it's easy sometimes to find a positive
control you know if this fire if this
assay will work to detect X virus but
it's oftentimes hard to find negative
controls
and so what we've done here is we've
looked at virus controls as a utility
uh sorry we've used respiratory controls
so the viruses here include
coronaviruses that are non-tarsity too
rhinoviruses MERS the original stars and
we asked if they could be used as a
negative control for an FDA approved CDC
qpcrs
our positive control is here we find
detection of our sequence as the top
orange bar and that bar chart and that
our negative controls are true negatives
and so if you're developing an assay
once you can detect sensitivity by using
your positive controls
but you can also detect your specificity
by using negative controls
so in the next slide we'll talk about
developing a hybrid capture workflow the
workflow is pretty simple it starts with
um
purified RNA
then treating that Library that's
capable of being detected in a Next
Generation frequency platform and then
going through hybrid capture and so how
can we use this workflow for an example
the characterization and the deception
of Sarasota V2
so
we've created a star W2 resource panel
at twist and it's designed and supported
by twist it creates biotinrelated probes
which covers the full genome
for exiled and you can use it to detect
single-stranded RNA what's really great
about this method is that it's a
target's a reference train but it's also
very tolerant to mutations and so you
can use it to characterize and detect
specific mutations that may not be
existed may not exist in the in the
reference sequence in the wild type
strings
uh this panel is capable of doing
significant enrichment for the full
genome from complex samples so what
we've done in this experiment is that we
use those synthetic controls that I've
just highlighted and we've used them in
Target enrichment to see how much we can
enrich for these samples so we either
started with a virus copy number of 1
million or one and we Spike that into
human genomic DNA traded our libraries
we went through our Target enrichment
and then we asked the question what was
the viral fraction post capture
and so you can see for the table on the
right if we started with a virus copy of
1 million we got 97.8 style fraction
post capture and not surprisingly that
number goes down uh when you started
with fewer viral copy numbers
but the fold enrichment is really
significant here and so when I look at
the fold enrichment of virus copy
numbers that were spiked in at 1 million
we had a 2 000 folded nurse plan but for
when we had 10 copies one copy that
number significantly higher
you know 800 000 fold higher uh that 800
000 fold enrichment of that virus
sequence you really can pull that needle
out of a haystack pull that virus that
copy loggers that are super low
from really complex samples
so that's an example of a panel that
targets one specific virus but can you
use a panel or can you use Target
enrichment to identify maybe viruses
that have similar symptoms but totally
different sequences
and so
can Target enrichment identify specific
viruses and so oftentimes diverse viral
species species or viral infections can
result in very similar patient symptoms
so like with the continuous threat of
viral diseases like influenza
renoviruses and coronaviruses we
recognize the need for an assay capable
from Multiplex to section of respiratory
pathogens
so we wanted to enable asset developers
through providing synthetic controls and
then we also wanted to create a Next
Generation Target enrichment workflow
that could be used to distinguish
between viral pathogens with very
different sequences
and so what you see here is that we went
through Target enrichment with this
respiratory panel and we looked at
different viruses from rhinoviruses
influenza viruses MERS cyroscopy 2 Etc
and then we asked the question can we if
we start how much enrichment can we get
for these different sequences
and are we able to cover the full genome
after Target enrichment
and so
if we use one million sequencing reads
all the templates are covered at a mean
dots of 15 net 1500x so you get
significant enrichment oh sorry you get
significant coverage of these templates
of these virus sequences now 99 of these
bases are covered to at least the 30X
coverage and that's really important
because especially for viruses like
influenza and Cyrus W2 so you're able to
do confident variant calling in De novo
assembly
a question that I often get asked is if
I have similar sequences or like
sequences will I be able to distinguish
determine what virus is which and so we
did that experiment we took our our
enrichment and we took down a reed and
we asked the question uh what do those
reads map to if I just pull down uh H1N1
will that map to any other viruses in
this panel and you can see on that heat
map on the right that there's a lack of
crosstalk between the viruses after
Target enrichment so you are capable of
pulling out specific sequences and
identifying what those specific
sequences are using Next Generation
sequencing Target enrichment
now here is
more of the same we're just highlighting
the fact that you can enrich for diverse
viruses with Target enrichment
and we're highlighting Multiplex capture
where there were multiple like multiple
viruses synthetic viruses present in
that capture and we asked the question
can we enrich for both of those
sequences at the same time and so
the answer is yes we can all the
templates were completely covered at 1X
for each co-infection experiment but
generally good at uniformity across all
templates
we again found that all all of the
viruses in the experiment had greater
than 99 basis covered at 30th coverage
except for the book of ours it
is a really interesting
case because it's the only
single-stranded DNA virus that we have
in this panel and what we found is that
the enrichment was actually quite good
but the we believe the overall coverage
was lower
to the lower lower Library prep
efficiency during the single strategy
from the single stranded DNA yeah
now lastly I want to highlight the fact
that Target enrichment one of the key
components here is that you're able to
enrich for novel variants
and so in this experiment we created
synthetic mutation
to a highly variable domain of the H1N1
influence stream and on the figure to
the right you look at the wild type you
look at the percent variation in the
sequence so we either have the wall tape
which is zero percent they went to five
percent
to 30 variation and granted we captured
all of these sequences with the same
probes and so that we ask the questions
to the panel you know the first panel on
the figure to the right is what were the
relative capture efficiencies and so you
can see that the relative capture
efficiency went down as the sequences
got higher in terms of their mutation
rates that's not surprising now what's
really exciting to me to see is that
you're able to look at the percent basis
that are covered even if you have a
different variation to the wild type and
so you can get 100 sequence coverage at
One X at 1X coverage even when you have
up to 10 of the sequence that's mutated
you can still capture a significant
fraction of the whole uh whole percent
covered as a whole percent sequence
covered even when you have up to 20 so
if you're a researcher trying to
identify rapidly mutating viruses or
emerging viruses you can use Target
enrichment to pull down the sequences
and that's really unique from ampliton
sequencing where you're dependent on
specific primers to bind and then
amplify through them that specific
primer binding will have less tolerance
to mismatches and so you won't be able
to select for it but variance as
efficiently
so what we've done here is talked about
research recently
and I want to go quickly into diagnosing
and detecting
Sarasota V2 or diagnosing covid-19 in
patients and so in an eua authorized
assay for the detection that starts with
E2
twist bioscience and biosha partnered to
build the SARS cov2 and gssa and so it's
using Next Generation sequencing Target
enrichment or hybrid hybridization
capture assay through the detection and
characterization of Surf City q and this
assay is composed of the Next Generation
sequencing wet lab components as well as
the dry lab or the bioinformatics to
determine the presence of the absence of
Sarasota B2 and then a little bit of
extras which I'll go into in a second so
if we look at the Twist by OSHA ngste
workflow again if there's a specimen
collection it's a sample collection it
goes into taking extracting those
nucleic acids so if you're adding RNA
converting it to cdna sample prep and
then there's Library prep where you
convert those sequences into uh true C
compatible libraries so for the Illumina
platform
San Andreas hybrid capture where you get
pulled down with the sarso V2 panel into
sequencing followed by data analysis and
then performing
now admittedly this is a little bit of a
wordy slide uh but broadly speaking the
SARS could be two at GFS it contains
five modules which I've just broken down
and what you see on the table uh on the
left is the different modules from
collecting your sequences and to refine
your RNA going to library prep
amplification
consequencing is that this is where the
disadvantage of NGS sequencing uh ngste
compares to qpcr the workflow is quite
long it can take up to 50 hours in total
but the results here I think are very
striking and definitely well worth the
extra time
so again
we highlight the synthetics art cov2 RNA
controls and holidays significantly
enrich but
again this is what I showed previously
what about patient samples
how how is this assay capable of
detecting something that may sound from
a patient and so
developing this essay there was clinical
performance and analytical sensitivity
tests that were done and so a total of
140 nasal swabs were collected fantastic
they were collected over two locations
there's
uh up to 80 Stars could be two positive
and 60 Negative they went through the
assay gone through data analysis and
then the report was given and so what we
highlight here in this next slide is
that for the eua Emergency youth
authorization computer essay if we had
positive samples and 30 negative samples
how did our testing care
and so
with the Positive uh
when we look at all of the samples that
we've collected over time we found that
there was a 95 concordance with positive
agreements or uh PPA and then there was
a 98.3 percent concordance with a
negative agreement so percent uh
negative agreement was an 98.3
also we found that the limited detection
for this assay was 800 copies per Mill
so it's a very small amount
this is another way of looking at
performance data for Next Generation
sequencing and then this time what they
what the researchers from biosha looked
at was what if you have different
patients with different viral loads so
the comparator assay what our gold
standard was qpcr so if you have a low
CT value you have an inverse amount of
virus and it's very high
so to the far left on the x-axis are
higher viral loads with low CT values
and then over the axis you have
different data points that indicate
diminishing viral counts and a higher CT
guys
and what this uh data shows is that
um we were able to get significant full
of enrichment across different types of
patient samples across different types
of viral is and that our full enrichment
was significantly higher our overall
Justice coverage was also quite high in
that when we looked at the presence at
the uh when we were able to look at the
full-length sequence at different depths
we were able to see the full sequence
now I highlighted uh for this diagnostic
assay it comes with a test report and
this is just the dummy report it's been
a test sample of what you get and for
the eua authorized test it will the
results summary will be as far as tested
or not detected and that's very common
for all Diagnostic assays in the space
do you see the virus yes no now for
researches only uh what we've done is
partnering with our partners at biosha
we've gone a little bit deeper and again
because SARS could be two for this
example is a rapidly mutating virus the
population you know distribution is
really important to understand
so for researchers only we've gone a
little bit above and beyond and uh
generated report to highlight genetic
theory it's detected sequence those
variants match across the genome and
then gone into and looked at the
different clades that are associated
with the different variant results
and so I just want to highlight some of
the scientists that did this work and
the fact to acknowledge that even with
this pandemic the EU approval process is
very it takes us quite a bit of time uh
this athlete was put in July 2020 and
accepted in March 2020 ounce one it's a
collaboration between twist and biosha
and I want to highlight some of the
specific numbers that's done an amazing
job in this it's really some technical
experts
so with that I thank you so much for
your time it's been a pleasure to talk
to you about a subject that I find to be
fascinating and very relevant which is
the use of hybrid capture technology to
recognize and characterize viral threats
a Twist you like to say science doesn't
stop and neither will me whether it's
the middle of a global pandemic or if
it's Tuesday you know we're here for you
what can twist do for you I hope that
this uh this webinar this educational
seminar has taught you a little bit
about hybrid capture and if you're
curious I would love for you to get in
contact come talk to us at twist and uh
let us know how what we can do for you
how can we enable your research thank
you so much for your attention